how are you Adam hello there dan how are
you doing I'm doing okay um are you uh
are you expecting Michigan to be in the
Final Four here do they deserve to be in
the Final Four having lost two of their
last three well will they be and will
they deserve two entirely different
things okay there was a video that was
sent to me the other night and I hate
when people complain about officiating
use excuses I'm just saying someone from
my school one of my college fraternity
brothers sent me a video that was a
three minute video of Ohio State
penalties strung together with the fact
that these officials were from Ohio and
about Ohio State's bands with them
padding Ohio State players on the bus
during the game I could play i'm
watching this video in amazement like it
looks like it's almost made up because
it can't be real like it was in credit
to Rich Eisen to take a look at and he
sent me back his podcast that he talked
about okay III wanted to see the video
because the video is so startling oh it
was Jory to watch all this doubt it I
don't think they'll make it no but it'll
be plenty of good seat is ahead and
hopefully they can bounce back another
year I'm not expecting to make it yeah
now there is I don't know what the
committee is but they look at potential
head coaching candidates in the NFL and
Jim Harbaugh's name was on that list i'm
sure you can clarify this but how does
his name get on that list of guys who
could be coaching or potential
candidates in the NFL just because you
on that doesn't mean he has interests in
doing that what happens is the NFL has
this committee that it puts together of
esteemed respected individuals they come
up and their job is to basically
nominate head coaching general manager
candidates in canada that they believe
would be very good for the league that
other teams should look at and nobody's
under any obligation they don't seek the
permission of these candidates that they
just basically make up this list and at
the situation where they could nominate
Jim Harbaugh because they think he'd be
an excellent selection for an NFL owner
which is who they are essentially doing
it for
but that doesn't mean that Jim Harbaugh
is gonna go to the NFL okay uh the the
big story the headline maker is a Rob
Gronkowski out with back surgery today
now has he done done even if they get to
the Super Bowl I cannot imagine that he
plays again this season I think he's
done for the season and then the
question is how effective is when it
comes back next season and that remains
a question this is his third back
surgery he misses entire year junior
year at Arizona because it back surgery
the reason he fell to the second round
of the trap was a first-round talent
here's 27 and backs are unpredictable
and temperamental nobody knows how
anybody's back is going to react every
third surgery playing the brand and
style of football that Rob Gronkowski
does so to me yeah he's done for the
season he won't be back even if they
make it to the Super Bowl and then the
question is how healthy is he next
season and beyond yeah he's going to be
an old 28 come next season the Chargers
with Los Angeles and I think they have
till january fifteenth if they want to
decide to opt out of that and or opt
into Los Angeles so is this bargaining
it is it leaked on purpose to Jim
Trotter of the mothership that this is
what the Chargers are going to do or do
you think that that's where they're
going Los Angeles I know people think
that there are motives all the time
behind stories and as somebody who
traffics in that world I just think that
that cynical jaded and maybe sometimes
accurate but not in this particular case
I know that Jim Rosario various people
has been going to various people he
lives in San Diego he's very connected
to that situation I spoke to Jim for a
while yesterday and my understanding
from speaking to him and speaking to
others is that barring anything
unforeseen at San Diego plans to
relocate to Los Angeles for next season
and the same is true the racers with Las
Vegas everybody keeps talking about the
fact that Oakland is trying to do
something for Mark Davis Mark Davis say
what you want about is very very loyal
very loyal and he has given Las Vegas's
word that if it would bill to miss
stadium
and do what it is said it would that he
would come and to me the Raiders are
going to Las Vegas pending me approve of
the league now that's another issue in
situations I don't think everybody man
FL office is to enroll with that idea
even though it's doing increasing
momentum among certain NFL owners I
think there are some people that are
resistant so this idea is still so there
could be a little bit of a fight behind
the scenes but make no mistake about it
Mark Davis wants to and intends to kk
keep the Las Vegas more likely to outlet
that's not leveraging more likely to
have a team in Las Vegas or two in Los
Angeles I didn't both of Abaddon I think
both are on their way to happening I
will be surprised if both don't happen
well I saw Adam Schefter is joining us
of course from the mothership but you've
added another job title you're now an
NBA insider well I wanted to be the
official ruler for you on the back porch
but they would not do that looked at me
for you and that was something they
could not get done for me so failing
that I decided to take on this new role
it showed this actually that my Boston
good friend Seth markman floated to me
he's like hey how'd you like to do some
sidelines for some NBA games and make no
mistake about it the people that we have
who do that job of tremendous your DARS
Burke and Jay adonde and March died and
Mark Jones all those people they do a
great job I'm not looking to infringe
upon their job in any way shape or form
nor could I all I'm looking for Dan is
my job which I love to death and
wouldn't trade for anything is so
intensive and so relentless that it
never lets up I cannot imagine going to
an assignment where I'm not just worried
all the time and paranoid about shaking
on everything and just able to be
assigned reporter and watch the cave and
observe it and report it that's not my
sport so I don't know what I'll do one
game three games five games i guess a
lot of that will depend upon how it goes
um and and will say but again I've done
this job before back at the NFL network
i was there thursday night sideline
reporter with the great Brian Gumbel and
Cris Collinsworth what we launched those
games I did that for a few years I love
doing it and this is a chance to just
get
do that again I don't want to punish
sure I think it'll be more fun than
anything else I've to really enjoy the
NBA over the last couple of years and
we'll see how it goes who would be
tougher to interview Popovich or
Belichick well they're both tough in
their own ways very tough I think listen
I'd love to get pop at half time for my
floor guys Brian winner was correcting
you say after the first quarter there's
no afternoon where I still get the
excuse me I experian as I told him
Rolanda me the time that I was an intern
in seattle in 1990 and i went into the
baseball managers office and i say coach
what are your plans for King graffiti we
walked out and I was quickly spoken to
he is not the coach is a manager don't
ever call him to koji je I don't know
that's here just annoys the adjustments
I'm about to make your dad because they
thought I don't know if you uh you heard
the controversial question and answer
that I had with Mike Florio from
wednesday's show what is that seton
plant better hear you or Schefter uh
well mine because I know it's real I
don't know what he's got Wow well I
haven't had a chance oh my god chef d
hair piece what I don't know that
hairline looks a little manufacturing
wow that is a hat looks like a row crops
to me at times dan man no there you go
Adam Wow is their legal action oh that's
very nice of him my hair is real it's
authentic it's you know I think my mom
my dad this just in Adam Schefter hair
is real no I am I will make an admission
here ok ok I I do take peds you didn't
you do perhaps your propecia
[Music]
hair asterisk by it though are you sure
is your hair going to be on the
commissioners exempt list there is that
what's going on I'm hoping I'm not just
after Sunday I could come up positive
because of those peds and that propecia
have taken in the past that could turn
up a positive test and I would hope that
ESPN would overlook that not to spend me
going forward that salary Florio is
watching right now is there a direct
response to Mike Lawrie item the facts
are the facts again you know I'm on my
performance enhancing devices for
enhancing drugs to preserve the hair
that I do have and I want to give a
shout out to my mom and dad for for
allowing me to be able to turn 50 and
have my hair well here's the key you're
like Andy pettite you admit it and then
you move on as opposed to stringing
people along that's the key that's the
key to doing it you know you're not
bonds you're Andy Pettitte well done
yeah yeah well done have a great weekend
Adam and thanks for joining me for the
interest we could dance Rob all right
let's Adam Schefter cleared that up gave
him a chance to respond and Mike Florio
I'm descend lawsuit and I've I got that
feeling right there that was slander the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]